Speaker 1: Donald Trump at 9 p.m. Eastern tonight
will be making an announcement. The expectation
is that he's going to announce he's running for
president, although there are many people telling
him don't do it, at least don't do it yet. Donald
Trump, in his infinite delusions of grandeur,
is saying that hopefully this announcement
will be one of the most important days in
American history. Think about that. Donald Trump
believes that whatever he's going to say tonight
and we will carry it live. Is going to be one
of the most important days in the history of
the United States. Talk about narcissism. Donald
Trump posting yesterday on his platform truth,
social censure. Quote, Hopefully tomorrow will
turn out to be one of the most important days in
the history of our capital C country. And then
again today, Trump posting Hopefully today will
turn out to be one of the most important days in
the history of our country. However, not everybody
thinks this is a good idea. Donald Trump's
final former press secretary, Kayleigh MCENANY,
says Trump should not declare
today. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: And that could go straight through
the state of Georgia to include Trump. I think he
needs to put it on pause. Absolutely. Look, he'll
make that decision or make his own decision. But
does he go too far in advising any contender?
DeSantis, Trump, whomever. No one announces
2024 until we get through December six. Do
you see the former president? I need for him
to go to Georgia. I think we've got to make
strategic calculations. Governor DeSantis,
I think he should be welcomed to the state
given what happened last night. You've
got to look you got to look at the realities
on the ground. And Herschel Walker, we've got
to win the Senate. That's a guy's got to win the
Senate. All right. We'll move on. The Democrats.
Speaker 1: First. Yeah. So Kelly doesn't think
this is such a good idea, at least not before
the December 6th runoff. Now, some have speculated
that Trump is going to change his plan tonight and
instead will announce something about Herschel
Walker. However, he's already scamming people
out of money, claiming it'll go to Herschel
Walker. It'll go mostly to him. I'll get to
that in a moment. Another person who doesn't think
Trump should be announcing tonight is Republican
Governor John Sununu. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: I know you say the media loves to talk
about Donald Trump and perhaps that's fair. But
it's not just the media. It's Donald Trump himself
and he's planning to announce for president.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry, you guys. It's Chris
Sununu. I apologize. Chris Sununu.
Speaker 2: Is that a good idea
for him? No, I think it's a terrible idea for
him. I was. Look, from just a purely political
standpoint, we still don't know what's going
to happen in Georgia. The votes are still being
counted in Nevada and and Arizona. By the way,
the point out in Nevada. In Arizona, where the
primary Nevada race is undecided. Yeah. Yes, there
is an arms race in Arizona still undecided, only
about 88 or 90%. And so we'll see where that
goes. But look, people want to move away from
politics as you hit Thanksgiving, as you hit
Christmas, as we're spending time with families,
as we're trying to figure out how we're going
to fill our oil tanks with all these high fuel
prices. So now is just a horrible time for big
political statements. Save that for early 23
would be my message. But either way, it doesn't
really matter. It's going to be great for the
media. Saturday Night Live will probably love
it, but for the rest of us, we're going to
focus on spending time with our families and.
Speaker 1: All right. So Chris Sununu does not
think Trump should announce his run for presidency
tonight. And here is Jason Miller, one of Donald
Trump's for a while closest advisers. He appeared
on Newsmax and he also said, I wouldn't make
this announcement on November 15th today.
Speaker 2: Now, you just said everything
over the next month is about Herschel Walker.
Having said that, I understood there could have
could be an announcement before that from
somebody that resides at Mar a Lago. So
does that change his plans as far as announcing?
Speaker 5: So no formal decision yet. Of course,
President Trump had said that he would be
making an announcement on November 15th,
next Tuesday. I'm advising the president
to hold off until after the Georgia race,
after Herschel Walker priorities A, B and
C need to be about Herschel. Right now,
this is bigger than anything else in the country.
We got to show the focus is on Georgia. Keep the
country rallying in really critical point here
is that Brian Kemp holds many of the cards for
what's going to happen with Herschel Walker. There
were a lot of the Kemp Warnock ticket splitters.
Kemp didn't do anything for Herschel Walker in the
general election. If Kemp wants to show that he's
a leader with some brighter future ahead of him,
that he needs to get out there and really hustle
for Herschel Walker. We need.
Speaker 2: All here.
Speaker 1: All right. So the point here is
Jason Miller is advising Trump not to do it,
but there is one person who thinks it would be
a great idea. It happens to be Donald Trump's
daughter in law, Lara Trump. When asked, given the
poor results in the midterms, should Donald Trump
really be announcing? And she said Absolutely.
Speaker 3: I don't think there's ever been a
better time, to be honest with you, for Donald
Trump to come back. Everywhere I go and I live
in obviously a very Republican state in the
state of Florida, all I hear from people is
we need Donald Trump back. We want him
back. Please tell us he's running. So I
don't think you can believe all the headlines.
Speaker 1: Yep. In her weird echo chamber bubble
where she lives. Lara Trump thinks there is no
better time than right now for Donald Trump to
announce we will carry the event. I'm not
even calling it the announcement anymore.
The event tonight, including reaction. We
will be going live at 8 p.m. Eastern. The
announcement at 9 p.m. Eastern. Join me on
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. And remember,
if you're not subscribed on YouTube, you really
should be youtube.com slash The David Pakman Show.